c'est un message bref et ferme joe biden
veut donner toutes ses chances à la
diplomatie avec la russie mais sans
relâcher la pression face au risque d'
attaques russes contre l'ukraine ne
savons pas si les unités militaires
russes eux rentrent en effet à leur base
nos analyses montrent encore que les
russes restent dans une position
menaçons et les faits demeurent en ce
moment la russie encore 150 mille
militaires déployés à la frontière
ukrainienne et biélorusses
une invasion restaurant au bowling ball
ses troupes sont désormais évalués à 150
milles alors que les américains
parlaient jusqu'ici de plus de 100000
quelques heures plus tôt la dîmière
poutine avait annoncé un début de
retrait des soldats russes massés depuis
plusieurs mois aux frontières du
craignent n sur ces images fournies par
l'armée les blindés sont chargés sur un
train pour être rapatriés le président
russe a confirmé l issue de sa rencontre
avec le chancelier allemand sa volonté
de poursuivre le dialogue pratique il
voulons-nous jani lane mois bien sûr que
non et maintenant c'est là qu'on a
avancé nos propositions pour un
processus de négociation au cas où est
donc passée les occidentaux ont
considéré ces annonces avec prudence et
compte entamer d'éventuelles
négociations uniquement quand la menace
d'une invasion sera totalement écartée
les paroles c'est bien nous attendons
les autres si les actes sont là ce sera
encore mieux ça c'est la première
priorité la désescalade la deuxième
priorité vous le savez bien monsieur le
député c'est de reprendre les
discussions sur le contentieux sur le
cren joe biden affirme que des sanctions
sont prêtes en cas d'invasion de
l'ukraine elle s'attaquerait aux
institutions financières et aux
industries clés pour la russie